[Music]
hello everybody welcome to the
minimalist podcast where we discuss what
it means to live a meaningful life with
less my name is joshua fields milburn
and i'm ryan nicodemus and together we
are the minimalists ryan on a long
enough timeline we all outgrow certain
things
material possessions careers cities
routines habits traditions
and even relationships what worked
yesterday might not work tomorrow so we
must constantly let go because if we
don't if we cling to the past
then we get dragged out of the present
moment today on the public minimal
episode of the minimalist podcast we're
talking about outgrowing things that no
longer serve us
we also have an exciting announcement
about our new podcast co-host
later in the episode make sure you stay
tuned for that then this thursday on the
minimalist private podcast ryan and i
are going to talk about why wanting less
leads to satisfaction you can check that
out at patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description your support keeps our
podcast and youtube channel 100
advertisement free because
say it with me y'all
advertisements suck
yeah they do
our first question today is from
facebook asha has a question for us how
can you tell when you've outgrown
something
well ryan let's talk about outgrowing
things so some things material
possessions right i think it often
starts with the stuff and it's easy to
recognize that we've outgrown a thing
literally like my daughter's nine she
can't fit into the
her clothes and when she was three those
are the easy things to identify right
i'd literally no longer fit into them
yes yeah yeah or maybe if i flip that
around this thing no longer fits into my
life yeah and so let's talk about some
of the things that we outgrow
stuff
yeah we'll get into that obviously we're
the minimalist careers you and i outgrew
some careers yeah i loved my career when
i first started right it was so exciting
i was like i was loving it like just
really enjoying the experience and at
some point the thing that was fulfilling
became the antithesis yeah of your
fulfillment of your satisfaction
cities you know we both grew up in and
around dayton ohio spent time in
cincinnati enjoyed those cities in fact
i still really enjoy dayton we lived in
missoula montana
for five years
and there was a point where i outgrew
that city personally i stayed there a
little bit too long and i think today we
may even talk about rob bell's analogy
of
graduation versus divorce
yeah because at some point
you become so discontented with the
thing that you've outgrown the city the
person the material possession that you
almost like renounce it you feel like
you have to get divorced from it yeah or
sometimes you can graduate from the
thing yeah um routines habits
even like our identity
yes yeah and in fact i think we have a
question in a little bit about identity
yeah and i want to talk to you about
identity because
i think our identities they shape who we
are
but also when we cling to that identity
it prevents us from being the person
that we want to be moving forward yeah
that is a clinging to the past as well
traditions certain family traditions you
know if if we've always done something
this way that's not a great reason to
continue to do it no i'm not against
tradition traditions are often in place
for reasons here's something that has
worked for a really long time but it
doesn't mean i'll never question this
tradition right because then we get
dragged by the tradition and then of
course relationships we all outgrow
relationships too often
what happens is
we get a divorce sometimes literally but
yeah but we have a big fight with a
close friend and the people we're
closest to what happens we often outgrow
that relationship because we're taken
for granted or we take other people for
granted yeah so to get back to the
fundamental question here and that's the
question i wanted to start the episode
with what all these things have in
common whether it's a material
possession
it's a city it's a routine it's a habit
it's a tradition it's a relationship
it's your identity
what do these things have in common well
for me
it's
the past that we hold on to we hold on
to this ideal version
i bought the shirt that was on the
mannequin because i thought it was going
to look great on me yeah but of course
i'm not going to look like the mannequin
ever even if i'm wearing the mannequin's
shirt
and so
what about the tradition well i kept
doing the tradition because that's what
my family did that's what my community
did that's what other people said i'm
supposed to do i'm supposed to celebrate
the fourth of july or christmas and
there's nothing wrong with those things
but if i'm doing it just because i'm
supposed to do it i may not even be
getting the benefit of it and then of
course with our material possessions
if i'm holding on to something that i've
outgrown that no longer fits into my
life then what am i doing i'm not making
space
for calm for peace you know i just moved
recently remind me to never move again
by the way
that's funny too because your furniture
you left it all you abandoned everything
i sold all of my furniture and it was
still a pain in the in the butt to move
huh and everything i own fits in my car
right but like a really skilled tetris
game okay uh but it all fit there so i i
mean
i made the drive up to ventura county
where we moved
and everything fit in my car but even
then i'm just like
there's something about my ocd is a
super power
and it is also kryptonite at the same
time right
and so goes life right and so if you
want a recipe to
stress me out is there's some growing
pains with this
yeah and i think that's how we start to
know this is what answer answers asha's
question when you start to feel some
sort of pain yeah it could be anxiety
yeah it could be stress yeah it could be
resentment ooh resentment's a big one
i think resentment we've far outgrown
the thing oh yeah resentment like yeah
that's when you are now
you know you're in the process of
divorcing the thing potentially yes yes
uh bex and i on her podcast called how
to love we did uh she called the
resentment episode it was episode 19 of
her podcast and we talked about
resentments we had toward each other and
it wasn't be from each other but it was
around the circumstances so sometimes
you can be with someone and there's joy
there's love same thing with the thing
but maybe you've outgrown the
circumstance in which you're in yeah for
bex that was living in montana for way
too long we for the longest time split
our time she split her time really
between montana and california until we
ended up getting custody of ella
recently
and so
now
we have outgrown that but because we
were sort of stuck there that pain we
felt there was some sort of pain
suffering that was involved
and so
the first sign that you've outgrown
something is that you feel something is
off
it's like here's the reverse of this
question how do you know you love
someone there's no checklist i can't say
well what do you love about ryan well uh
he has beautiful blue eyes he has a
handsome smile thank you he's kind he's
compassionate and i can name eight other
things right mention my hair
[Laughter]
not in the top dozen
and i could name a dozen things about
you
and then i could find a million other
people several million other people with
those same characteristics but i may not
feel the same way toward them
that i do toward you well why is that
because there are certain unnameable
characteristics that yes we can put
labels on them we can put pro and con
lists together
and that can be helpful in some context
but ultimately you know there's a inner
feeling there's a heart feeling
oh
i'm holding on to this thing it's no
longer serving me or
here's the other thing ryan
we learned this a couple episodes ago we
did um we were talking about joshua
becker's uh he has this rule
um
where he
uh
this would have been great for the the
minimalist rule book by the way but his
rule was
just because you use a thing doesn't
mean you need to own it um
and
what i loved about that is it almost
flies in the face of our 90-90 rule our
90-90 rule is have i used this thing in
the last 90 days if not will i use it in
the next 90 days yeah if not i give
myself permission to let go but what
josh joshua becker's doing he's taken
even a step farther and he's saying hey
yes maybe i have used this in the last
90 days and i noticed this when i was
moving ryan i started looking at what i
would call obsolete objects
something i would make an excuse to use
once a month or whatever just because oh
i want to make sure i keep it
but maybe i'd be better off
or at least just fine without that
excess thing
maybe i've outgrown it and i don't even
know i've outgrown it but i also feel
that sense of relief when i let go which
is another rule you and i have with the
spontaneous combustion rule yeah if
you'd feel a sense of relief
if you got that relationship that city
that
routine that habit that tradition that
person out of your life
if you'd feel a overwhelming sense of
relief that's probably a sign that
you've outgrown
that thing yeah
yeah
let's move on to our callers ryan if you
have a question or comment for our
podcast give us a call 406-219-7839
or email a voice memo to podcast at
theminimalists.com
it looks like one of our patrons christy
has a question for us she's from belle
fountain ohio represent
two months ago i left my now ex-husband
due to an increasingly abusive situation
in the time since i moved back to my
hometown and church began working two
jobs i love and found a counselor who is
able to challenge me in the areas i need
it most
for the first time in a long time i'm
safe stable and gradually healing i have
a very good friend who i'm interested in
on a more intimate level historically
i've let my his significant others
pursue me but i want to take a chance
and pursue him i don't plan on launching
into a relationship until i'm ready for
it but i want to be honest about how i
feel now
my fear is that if i haven't dealt with
all of my issues i'll be using this
person or any person i choose to be
intimate with in an unhealthy way
i don't want to burden anyone else with
the weight of healing my scars how do i
move forward with relationships
christie this is a really
mature
view that you have here i love some of
the words that you used
but i really love the essence behind
these words you talked about safety you
know being safe stable
healing
i mean when ryan and i the reason we do
this podcast is to help people heal
their relationships whether that's your
relationship with stuff your
relationship with people your
relationship with yourself
and you also what you're trying to do is
not burden others how loving and
compassionate is that because quite
often when we enter into a relationship
what's the first thing we try to do
change that person oh they're great
except this list of four dozen things
and if i just start changing them one by
one we don't realize what we're doing
there is we are burdening
someone else yeah and where christie is
right now is she has
well she has
outgrown a previous relationship but i
think more important than that ryan she
has outgrown a previous mindset
where we often don't know that we're
doing this but she said it in her
question we use people we use people to
heal ourselves right to improve
ourselves to make ourselves happy and on
the maximal episode this week we're
going to talk about how to be satisfied
how to want less but really where does
satisfaction come from where does
fulfillment come from and i will tell
you this christy is no matter what
relationship you bring into your life
they can't make you happy
and that is probably the most difficult
thing to
truly understand even when you start to
understand it intellectually
yeah but i kind of feel like i'm happier
when i'm
when i'm around ryan when i'm around
professor sean i'm happier when i'm
around these people right
well okay
but they didn't make me happy there's a
great schopenhauer quote he talks about
how
a
man
man isn't happy
isn't
happy because he's in paris he
happiness appears within him when he is
in paris it's not that paris made him
happy but maybe he set up the
environment for that happiness which is
innate to
come out
from within yeah
it's interesting like what do we say um
all relationships make you miserable yes
every relationship has a little bit of
misery with it so you know for as much
as a relationship makes you happy
there's always like that counterbalance
so so christy i think that's one thing
to note is that no matter what
relationship you get into there's going
to be points of contention disagreements
whatever that may be
um for me like a couple thoughts going
on like one is
you know the unhealthy uh she used you
know that word unhealthy she doesn't
want to be an unhealthy relationship due
to not dealing with her trauma
so when does that become unhealthy for
me it's it would be if i'm using a
person
to cover up a trauma
so if i'm like using that to like avoid
that's that's when it's unhealthy
so i mean i think that's probably how
you can that's how i would gauge it uh
christy is looking at whether or not i'm
using this person to avoid something
some kind of pain
um rather like i would find a partner
and mariah does really well with this
with me like i will um you know have
some trauma stuff come up and like you
know i'll hit it head on and like you
know i'll talk to her about it and uh
yeah it's great we have a great
relationship when it comes to that and
vice versa and then the other thing too
is man um
one thing to avoid for me
because i've had some pretty crappy
relationships and you know crappy
childhood and all that stuff i mean
i i was talking to colin wright
yesterday i'm like dude you have no idea
how lucky you are to not have traumas
he was raised with like the best parents
the best siblings they're like yeah
they're all amazing anyway but my wife
grew up in a
very similar household so i'm so envious
of people who don't have the level of
trauma that like you and i had but most
people i feel like most people actually
have had a pretty high level of trauma
growing up yeah but uh what i'm getting
at is is when
in our adult life and we talked about
this with oh i forget her name but um we
were talking about when these tr when
these things come up um trauma has
created a mechanism to protect us so
when we're in an adult relationship that
mechanism that we use as a kid will come
up and then you know that sometimes will
push people away or like it escalates
the situation
and you've got to realize in the moment
that like okay like that
that is a mechanism that used to work it
doesn't work anymore
and if i if i
if i uh use this mechanism it's gonna
make the relationship worse
so you know long story short is that's
something that i have to look out for
with me and mariah is like she said
something to me the other day i'm like
my ex-wife used to always say that i
used to get so mad like she said um she
said something like man your mom really
did uh
your mom really um set you up for
addiction or something i forget what
mariah said and my ex-wife used to
always say man your mom did a number on
you and every time she said that i would
be like like i would get so angry at it
yeah and mariah said it the other day
and i was like
it's like i was like my ex used to say
that just make me so much she's like oh
i'm sorry i'm like no i'm like at 40
years old i can hear it
like i'm not i'm not upset by it anymore
like i get it
and um that mechanism that did start to
come up i'm like well hold on a second
man like not two people are telling you
this like maybe you want to listen to it
so you got to watch out for um
yeah just these different uh techniques
we used to use to avoid the trauma we
don't have to use those techniques in
our future relationships the thing about
trauma too is it is highly personal
highly perspectival highly individual
meaning a thing that traumatizes me may
not have any effect on you and vice
versa right sure and i think we overuse
that word quite a bit in today's sort of
online vernacular where we we talk about
everything as a trauma and the reason i
bring that up is that's not what
christie is talking about here she's
talking about legitimate traumas that
she's still having trouble letting go of
from the past because it is possible
that you get to a point there are things
that were traumatizing to me when i was
little that i have no sway over me
whatsoever now but that has to do with
letting go how do i let go i stop
clinging to those things now
how do you do that well there is no
how-to here right it's about a deep
understanding of that that thing in my
past
that did define me at the time
main doesn't have to continue to define
me going forward i do want to talk about
one other thing real quick ryan that you
mentioned every relationship will bring
you misery
and while that's true it's not the
relationship of course it's not the
other person right right it's always me
who makes me miserable yes it's me who
is angry it's not that ryan has the
power to anger me only if i give him
that power
i'm explaining this to my nine-year-old
daughter now at this point and she's
beginning to finally
understand all i mean which is amazing
at nine she's able to grasp this like oh
yeah
other people
can't embarrass me only i can embarrass
me
and you see that switch within her right
and everything else is true within the
relationship that other person if they
help set up the environment for calm for
peace
wonderful
however
if you are
dating someone seeing someone being
intimate with someone and they're
creating an environment of chaos
for you
that's not something i value some people
do value chaos and that's okay right
it's not that chaos is bad and peace is
good
personally i value i overvalue peace i
overvalue tranquility six days a week i
have incredible calm and peace in my
life and then i come here one day a week
and all of you are driving me insane
you're welcome
but really he's driving him he's driving
himself insane that's really what he's
trying to say that's exactly it uh
christy i want to send you a copy of our
book everything that remains so
my favorite chapter in that book is
actually one chapter in which ryan
doesn't appear
in the whole book
it's called harvest moon actually it's
about a relationship i really screwed up
and i didn't realize i screwed was
screwing it up at the time it's one of
the quickest things i ever wrote i wrote
this chapter ryan i was in a hotel in
billings montana like an old cowboy
hotel and i wrote it in like one night
and you know me it takes me forever to
write just about anything and the way
it's published in the book is about 95
the way that i wrote it that first night
and it's about really screwing up a
relationship and the lessons i learned
from that fall
because
what i realized there's an us box in
every relationship and i was just taking
from the s box i was no longer
replenishing it and no wonder i was
miserable i felt like a parasite
to her it felt like a parasitic
relationship
and so christy i think there are some
wonderful lessons in that chapter in
particular the book is called everything
that remains it's ryan's and my second
book it's our most popular book of all
time
and uh if you want to if you're
listening to this you want to check it
out
you can check out the audiobook the book
book or the ebook christy will send you
whichever of those that you'd like
ryan what time is it you know what time
it is it's time for the lightning round
where we answer your text messages you
can text your questions your comments to
937-202-4654 yes indeed now during the
lightning round this is where ryan and i
do our best to answer your questions
with a short shareable less than 140
character response we put the text to
these minimal maxims in the show notes
so you can copy and share our pithy
answers on social media if you'd like
and thanks to our good friends social
jess you can find all of our pithy
sayings over at minimalmaxims.com
alabama it looks like morgan has a
question for us how do you outgrow
something without feeling like you're
losing a part of your identity ryan i
was reminded of i heard rahm das give a
talk about this once in front of a small
group of people
and he's just so like
playful and jovial
and
he was like just ribbing the people
there because someone asked a question
similar to this about identity yeah and
he said oh look at you isn't that cute
you think you have an identity
yeah and how funny is that like we we
create this construct like yes i
understand what you mean by the term
identity yeah and so i have a pithy
answer for you but also understanding
that your identity
is more malleable and certainly more
fluid
than you might think by the time you get
to ryan's and my advanced age
[Laughter]
we have done an interview for aarp
magazine oh my gosh
minimizing for seniors
[Laughter]
so when you get to our advanced stage
you um you start to realize you start to
believe like here's who i am as a person
i am solidified yeah but when you were
nine it wasn't like oh this is my
identity yeah like i was a skater in
high school i don't i'm not a skater
anymore and yet we cling to those things
well beyond like to me and still in my
mind i'm still a basketball player i
haven't played basketball in a decade
over a decade yeah but you still
identify with the basketball player yes
although like you i'm way better at ping
pong than i am basketball
i don't identify as a ping-pong player i
why which is because i i've chosen in my
mind to hold on to that yeah and so
that's something for me to work on
letting go of right because i'm
certainly not that like i enjoyed
playing basketball once upon a time i
still enjoy watching it from time to
time but
that's not really who i am as a person
so here's something pithy for you your
identity is contaminated
by the residue of the past
and so that being a basketball player is
some residue from my past right and so
instead of keeping things on to my
identity it's like
sometimes we have a the analogy i used
in our book love people use things is
like trying to
paint a burning house um that's what we
often do with our identities yeah i have
you know a house that is infested with
termites let's say you wouldn't just go
and paint the house over and over you
know what this needs a new coat of paint
right in fact we had termites here
recently which i think we're still
dealing with dude that's that's los
angeles but yeah it's a different
conversation and so
but we didn't just paint oh i guess
we'll paint over the floor right that'll
make it better put more carpet down
mallory
termites can't eat carpet
and so but that's what we do with our
own lives like we will try to just cover
up up our self
with more identity i need to identify
with new things better things the past
didn't work for me so i'm going to heap
on more stuff to my life i bought the
wrong things and so we have all this
residue from the past
the real identity is underneath all of
that it's the letting go of that residue
that we've been clinging to which brings
in my second pithy minimal maxim here
and i said this a version of this during
the intro ryan if we cling to the past
we get dragged
out of the present yeah and
unfortunately
i'm really good at dragging myself out
of the present moment i'm very future
oriented i'm always thinking about
what's the next thing i can do what am i
doing tomorrow what's on the to-do list
where are we going this weekend let's
plan two months in advance what's the
next trip whatever it is and nothing
wrong with planning nothing wrong with
looking in the rear view from time to
time but if we just drive staring up at
this rear view mirror
we're gonna hit the car that's right in
front of us because it takes us out of
what's going on right there in front of
us same thing is true with if i'm just
staring at the horizon in perpetuity i'm
not seeing what's going on right here in
front of me yeah
man my pet the answer is this morgan we
are defined by our character not our
things
so i think about going back to the
skater thing when i was in high school
um my dad would not let me wear skater
clothes because it looked worldly but i
really enjoyed skating i wasn't like
good at it or anything but i really
enjoyed it you just found the jenko
jeans yeah right exactly you would not
let me get janko jeans so um i remember
like talking about skating and this kid
was like you don't skate like look at
you you don't i'm like because of the
clothes i wear like that means i don't
he's like yeah i was like
my dad would bring me to walmart and
like
you know buy me wrangler jeans which are
now cool
but like back in back in our day where
angular jeans were not the cool jeans
they have they have wranglers over at
kiss now it's so it's wild man that's
why i don't think change so anyway
um eventually i did start to get get
more you know baggier clothes yada yada
yada yeah finally like talk my dad you
know to not full janko but like you know
as far as i could get with the big with
the big pants
yeah wide cut yeah anyway
um but i felt like i had to have the
things to be that identity but like i
didn't really need the clothes to enjoy
skating right so um yeah i mean yeah uh
it's it's what you do like your actions
that you know is a big piece of your
character like what are you doing that's
who you are doesn't the things you own
don't make you who you are they can
accentuate it sure yeah they can
highlight some things i think about
someone like david bowie
who was this eccentric person and then
his style wardrobe makeup
surroundings yeah photos
everything about his life sort of
accentuated highlighted
the person who he was but i could put
those same clothes on ryan
and you'd just be like what is he doing
or you could take all of those things
away from david bowie and he would still
produce some amazing
music he'd still be david bowie
ryan we got a bunch more to talk about
including our new podcast co-host he'll
be joining us by phone here in a moment
but first alabama what do you got for us
here are some voicemail comments and
insights from our listeners
hi my name is aubry from lehigh utah and
i was just calling to say that something
that is difficult for me is to get rid
of items that people give me as gifts
but something that i have learned is
asking the question
has this served its purpose or has it
helped me feel
the love that that person has for me if
the answer is yes then it serves purpose
and i feel confident that i can get rid
of it
hi this is generally from salt lake i
was calling in regard to the episodes
about relationships
and um
being i guess content the comment that i
wanted to make is um
both i think as a single person and as
you're looking for a relationship when
you are
content with who you are before you go
into
a wanting a new job or say exactly
relationship um i think that is where
you build a better relationship than you
could if you were looking for someone
else to fulfill that or if you were
looking for fulfillment through a job or
doing you know the next project a um and
the thing that i have found in my life
that makes me content or makes me at
least
aware of what i need to change in order
to be content is gratitude if i am
grateful for the things that i have in
my life even the negative things um that
teach me patience or that teach me
compassion or that teach me
to be frugal
then
i am content
uh i may want to change but i am content
with who i am in that moment and i think
that has for me been the essential point
of being a happy person um is to be
grateful for the needs that i have
all right y'all real quick for right
here right now we have big news a
special announcement nicodemus heck yeah
we have a new co-host we have a new
format jordan i want to make this a
youtube breakout so stay tuned for that
so
where do we start ryan well
after 350 episodes yes we've sort of
outgrown our current podcast
format
so beginning august 1st 2022 with
episode 351
we'll have a brand new podcast co-host
and a new podcast format let's talk
about what that means real quick so
first off the first thing you're going
to notice is we're going to start
releasing our public and private podcast
episodes both on the same day on mondays
going forward why well because
no matter which version you subscribe to
the public or the private version we
want to start your week with a dose of
simplicity we're also combining the
minimal and maximal episodes for our
patreon subscribers so if you are a
supporter of the podcast you no longer
have to download two separate episodes
we've heard you loud and clear patrons
you don't have to record download an
episode on tuesday and then do one on
thursday and they're not two separate
episodes it's gonna be one giant episode
for you each week a whole lot more
of
less
so
don't worry both the minimal and the
maximal episodes are still going to be a
hundred percent advertisement free
because advertisements still and always
will
suck so big thanks to our patreon
supporters who do keep the podcast
advertisement free if you're a public
podcast listener you just listened to
the public version of the podcast we've
heard you loud and clear as well
you know i know that you want you've
been saying hey we want shorter
shareable
episodes of the free public version so
what ryan and i have decided to do
is the public version of the podcast all
of the same sort of segments added value
right here right now callers lightning
round silly jokes
going to see that
but it's going to be about 20 minutes
every monday so the free minimal episode
every monday 20 minutes short shareable
we'll also be sharing every day thanks
to danny unknown we're going to share
every day on tick tock and instagram a
one minute podcast clip every single day
you're going to see one of those make it
short shareable you can share that with
your friends family etc as for the
private podcast ryan
well we're increasing our private
maximal episodes on patreon to two plus
hours every week and with our new
co-hosts who knows they might be three
or four hours
they'll be joining us on the phone here
in a second to talk about that but we're
expanding
the private podcast including some new
segments ryan came with this great idea
for a masseter trash it hmm where
audience members can come to us and say
hey i've got this item should i keep it
should i let it go
i wonder if we're just going to tell
everyone i'll just let it go i'll just
let it go probably
well
i was thinking about that time we were
on wait wait don't tell me and they had
us do um kind of an amass a masseter
trashy type thing where basically
someone called in with an item and then
they told us to pick a side so they were
like all right josh on this item you are
for it and you ryan are against it
and uh yeah we just had like like an
antique doll i remember
i remember you getting all the like the
easy sides though where it was so it was
like every time that uh you had an item
like whatever side you were on that's
probably what they should have done and
it wasn't always get rid of it so yes i
imagine that there's gonna be some times
where we're like hey look sounds like
you get a lot of value out of that keep
it that's a great metaphor too someone
else it's always easier for them to let
go of it right right and i think that's
why people are going to call in and we
can tell them what we think would i hold
on to this if i was in your circumstance
or would i let it go and what would be
the best way recycle it sell it etc some
other new segments that we're going to
be working on on the private podcast
ryan advertisements suck where we review
a sucky advertisement we'll just look at
our sucky ad talk about why it's
terrible why it's influencing us and
what to do about it as well
up for discussion a little debate that
we'll have with our new co-host me you
and him we can debate just different
topics so yeah up for discussion is a
another podcast segment obsolete objects
really looking forward to this one
so what i've realized we had this uh
this gal gemma she one of our patreon
subscribers she was talking to me about
this the other day she's like i love how
you
show me that certain things i've always
thought i'm supposed to have
like dryer sheets or
cashews or wi-fi at home or whatever it
might be
fabric softener like maybe i don't need
deodorant it's not that it's bad
but i can start questioning the things
that i thought were a must for me yeah
so every week we're gonna do that
segment on the private podcast as well
and then also photo fridays we're gonna
start posting a photo of one of our
homes
and we can have a discussion the three
of us
where we're talking about oh you know
what here's like it's like a home tour
basically
but we're talking about hey here's what
my living room looks like right now i
just moved recently look at all the
clutter that comes from moving and so
having honest discussions about real
life minimalism in our own homes plus a
bit more also ryan on the minimal and
maximal episodes we're finally gonna
start taking live callers on the air
yeah so think about dave ramsey or dan
savage or your favorite radio call-in
show
we're gonna be interacting with you our
callers live on the air so instead of
people just calling in leaving a
voicemail which we'll still do that
we'll still have you call on the
voicemails but if it requires expanding
upon their question and and we had a
question today from christy would have
been great to get her on the phone and
say hey tell me more about this past
relationship or the past trauma what
traumas are you experiencing
uh in in your life and having that
dialogue with someone will really help
us get to the root of the suffering the
suffering with material possessions with
relationships with any other
clutter that we bring into our lives
and let's talk about the archives real
quick ryan this is a big one for us we
are archiving the first 300 episodes
of the minimalist podcast exclusively on
patreon why well
because we don't think the first 300
episodes are the best places to start
yeah you can go back into the archives
if you want sure it's just five bucks to
join patreon so you can get all 300
episodes still it's yeah you know for
five bucks you'll never get more content
than that yeah and so but what we're
gonna do is we want people to listen to
the newer version of the podcast first
so the most recent 50 episodes roughly
will continue to be free free to the
public of the minimal version of the
podcast but all of our archives if you
do want to dive back into those you can
but we recommend starting with and
sharing the most recent episodes first
everything from episode 300 on is much
closer to how ryan and i think these
days it doesn't mean there's not value
in going back to episode zero zero one
like millions of you have done at this
point a lot of people like to start at
zero zero one yeah and we just think
that's not the best place to start
probably not but there's like a
completionist in all of us that wants to
like
have it in numerical order i've done
that with some podcasts and realized
like okay i need to like i need to
probably skip ahead a thousand or two
episodes or just go backwards if you're
a conversationalist like me you can just
work your way back down episode one if
you'd like and so
that is the archives you can find all
those patreon.com slash the minimalist
oh and finally ryan we totally buried
the lead but we did so intentionally
joining us by phone calling from the
front seat of a u-haul moving truck
is our brand new co-host
ladies and gentlemen tk coleman yeah
what is going on fellas tk why the hell
are we doing this yeah ma'am
say what i said why the hell are we
doing this
oh man because it's a hell yes man
hell yes
i heard someone say that uh
you know uh if there ever was such a
thing as a perfect team uh it would
cease to be perfect the moment that you
got there you guys were too perfect man
i had to come in and corrupt stuff
that's right
no
you know seriously um
in all honesty man i say
you know i've always agreed with that
whole statement about
you don't want to always be the smartest
person in the room but you don't you
also don't want to always be the dumbest
person in the world you don't want to be
the smartest because you can't learn you
don't want to be the dumbest because you
can't contribute and so you always want
to live your life kind of like in a
mixture of those two spaces where you
are contributing but you are also being
positively challenged and i felt like
man we've always had this
great sense of camaraderie and this
great chemistry between the three of us
but what really binds us together for me
is the way we disagree that's what
really makes me say
i love these guys man and i want to keep
working with these guys at a higher
level because
the manner in which we disagree
just contributes so significantly to my
own personal growth and i know that that
that you guys would say the same about
me and so i'm excited not only about the
chemistry and camaraderie and
brotherhood that we have but i'm also
excited about our differences and the
way we embrace that the way we lean into
that the way we can have so much joy in
discussing those things together so
that's i mean it just makes sense to me
man i'm just really looking forward to
this yeah man me too it's interesting
because like i look at josh and i like
yin and yang
what do you when you add a third
personality and like what now what now
what can we compare to because we need a
new we need a new metaphor we need a new
metaphor yeah i think it's a a table you
have a table with three legs uh okay and
if you remove one leg
the table falls over right right but
like what we're going to do is we're
building something new like i said
without we have 350 awesome episodes
minimal episodes maxwell episodes all
out there
this huge archive
that has been an exploration for us yeah
but i'm totally with you
we can disagree in ways where we're not
arguing we're not fighting and we can
help each other see our perspectives
sometimes it changes our mind sometimes
it doesn't but the dynamic between the
three of us is we tend all three of us
tend to be just a little bit off from
where the other one is
and so we're it's like in the studio
we've got a light behind me a light
behind ryan it takes each light in order
to shine the light appropriately and i
think the same is true with the three of
us and we've done
a bunch of podcasts now with tk we've
done a bunch of live events with him as
well this seems to me like the natural
progression and so we're really going to
be expanding on both the free minimal
episodes and the private podcast
episodes as well if you are a podcast
supporter don't worry i know inflation
is affecting everyone but the
minimalists aren't raising your prices
in fact without raising prices we're
going to inflate the value of what we're
giving you over on patreon see what you
did there hey as a matter of fact josh
and ryan have me living in a box that's
how we can all afford to do this exactly
100
[Laughter]
so if you're not yet subscribed to the
private podcast we hope you'll join us
visit patreon.com
the minimalists or click the link in the
description just give it a month
starting with episode 351
keep in mind you're not going to have to
download two separate episodes now
you're going to start getting everything
on mondays this is going to be
just an amazing change for us
and for those of you who are afraid of
change don't worry you still get your
minimal episode every week you still get
all the stuff we share for free
all of that is still out there we're not
changing that we're not taking something
away from you in fact we're adding a
whole lot more
of what really matters
so if you want to subscribe patreon.com
the minimalist you'll get a personal
link so you can play our weekly private
podcast in your favorite podcast app you
also gain immediate access to hundreds
of hours of private archives recordings
of live events and our community of
thousands of open-minded minimizers
like you tk is there anything else that
we need to add today
hey man i'm just looking forward to the
fun that's one of my favorite quotes
from seth godin find the fun and
whatever you do find the fun i think
about that movie the way of the peaceful
warrior
where uh the young athlete who shattered
his leg in an accident
uh said i can no longer do what i love
and his mentor said to him
that when a true warrior is incapable of
doing what he loves he learns how to
find the love in what he does and i love
working with you guys but what i love
most is your ability to find the love in
everything that you do so i'm looking
forward to this man i'm looking forward
to creating fun together finding the fun
together and uh and just bringing a new
level of value to the people out there
that have grown together with you guys
over the years and have found so much
meaning and value in the work that you
do i'm really looking forward to
contribute to that yeah this is going to
take it to a whole new level tk we love
you we appreciate you brother thanks so
much we'll see you soon
much love guys
all right before we get to our added
value segment here's a thoughtful
testimonial from one of our lovely
patreon subscribers carrie says
wow this is great i really enjoy the
private podcast it's so candid and
genuine
a separate sentence here and funny
that's all you ryan it's just my it's
cause i look funny because you giggle so
much and also mallory makes us seem at
least fifteen percent 100
yeah she laughs at everything i love it
it's great for the con it's great for
confidence kerry says i'm honored to be
part of this advertisement free space
you both inspire trust we as listeners
know there is nothing you want from us
except an open mind
yeah i don't even know if i want that
from you i certainly don't want to like
mind from you and that's why we're
bringing tk on board here as well
because it's not about having people
with like minds yes having an open mind
is great so hopefully you'll join us
over there for the private podcast or
we'll continue to see you on the public
podcast for added value this week ryan i
have two things for you what do you got
you know i just moved to ventura county
and uh one of my favorite thinkers lived
there for a long time his name is jay
krishnamurti
and he has a wonderful book called think
on these things i was gonna bring a copy
but all my books are still in two
different boxes and i haven't unpacked
them yet
and so um
i'm sure jordan right here can place the
cover if you're watching the youtube
video version of the podcast think on
these things if you're looking to think
differently to understand differently
not the way that society has programmed
you but to sort of undo some of that
programming then think on these things
is a just a great book we're recording
this the day after the fourth of july
fireworks day as ella calls it
i call it world war three here in los
angeles oh yes it's crazy man
for new year's and fourth of july like
the fireworks start like right before
sunset so call it like 8 p.m
8 30 p.m and then they don't stop till 3
o'clock in the morning i've never been
in a city where like they go that long i
mean and it's just like because we were
up in pasadena so we were watching the
rose bowl fireworks which were really
cool like i got friends who live close
to there so we just like go up the hill
a little bit and you kind of look down
on the fireworks but then in the
distance like downtown past downtown
whatever that is on whatever part of los
angeles that is yeah south l.a yeah it's
just like
it's
there's not one second without like two
or three fireworks going on for hours
hours
the view from my old apartment condo
in west hollywood
had this great south facing view and it
was just it looked like there was a war
like you saw a war going on outside my
window
it's a little terrifying the first time
that you see it you're like what is
going on and then the next even this
morning i was driving into la county
like the the whole basin is there's
still smoke and smog and from the night
before
the smoke was particularly bad last i
haven't seen it that bad it's in the
five years we lived here but anyway so
there's a new song there's a new song
that we were listening to because ella
kept asking me to listen to it over and
over and over yesterday
and because she
really enjoyed the song you know me i
don't typically enjoy country music that
much but occasionally there's a song
that
it'll just it'll get me and you start to
get the vibe i don't know i and so this
one is by a guy named mike who had one
of my favorite albums from last year his
name is just mike m-i-k-e period
and another guy named skeeze
and it's called country anywhere
and
ella just had this song can we listen to
it again can we listen to it again can
we listen to it again so i'm sure you
hear it playing in the background right
now
enjoy country anywhere by mike and skis
by the way ryan we got a bunch more
surprise questions this week like i have
an expansive collection that i've
outgrown and no longer enjoy
is it worth trying to sell it even if i
don't think anyone else would want it
what is the perfect amount of clothes to
wear as a minimalist ron i have a
specific answer for this one an actual
answer
is
live every day like it's your last good
advice
or horrible advice let's argue about
that ryan you can check that out this
week over on patreon this thursday
patreon.com the minimalists you can
follow the minimalists on tiktok
instagram facebook and twitter at the
minimalist if you want our podcast show
notes in your inbox sign up for our
email list over at theminimalists.com on
behalf of ryan nicodemus malabama
podcast sean jordan no more professor
sean social jess danny unknown
post-production peter emma the immigrant
and chrissy still needs a nickname here
and the rest of our team my name is
joshua fields milburn
if you leave here today with just one
message
let it be this
love people
and use things
because the opposite never works
thanks for listening y'all we'll see you
next time
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
you think that you need
every little thing
that's just feeding your greed oh i bet
that you'll be fine without it